[Music]
hi
my name is maya ganz and in this talk i
want to tell you how to start
your own virtual book club
so this idea came to me in the beginning
of lockdown
i found myself feeling really alone
and also scrolling through twitter i saw
everyone taking on these new exciting
hobbies like remember the time when
there were so many pictures of sourdough
so i was looking at my bookshelf and i
saw advanced r
and i realized that's a book that i use
as a reference
but i never read cover to cover so i
wanted to use the lockdown opportunity
to do that
and i found myself asking a lot of
questions that i didn't have the answers
to
so i reached out to john harmon the
moderator of the r for data science
slack channel
and he allowed me to start a book club
channel within that slack and to kind of
just see what happens
and the results were magical 12 of us
ended up meeting weekly for the entirety
of the book so i think over the course
of 25 weeks and we went from essentially
a group of strangers to now a group of
really good friends so
first i want to talk about the
cornerstones of why
i think that this worked and the reasons
are twofold
we created a microcosm within an already
existing community
so you might say there's already our
ladies or
other chapters and groups out there and
that's true
but that's thousands of faceless
uh group members who albeit are
extremely helpful and inviting
whereas this group was 12 of us meeting
on zoom with the camera on
and really uh humanizing
uh this learning experience with each
other the other component was that we
made this as asynchronous compatible as
possible
so each meeting was recorded and put on
youtube so if you couldn't
attend you can watch that but we also
have this slack channel for people to
ask
questions and even answer them whenever
they get to them
so you weren't really limited and locked
down to this single
hour now
the meetings themselves kind of changed
over time what we did with them
in the beginning we took the first 30 or
so minutes to review what we found in
the chapter
and then use the rest of the time to
answer questions
but after a couple weeks maybe around
week eight or so
i was getting kind of bored with this
model and i
wanted to make an application i made a
shiny app that
uh uses the concepts within a chapter
and granted the shiny app was super
buggy
didn't even work but within the hour we
all debugged it
together and got it up and running and i
think that was kind of a paradigm shift
where people started rather than just
relaying information
they uh showed us their packages or
other creations and it was incredibly
inspiring
and um eye-opening to see
how people are using these fundamentals
just uh in these chapters
so now let's get to the secret sauce of
why i think
this model worked right we're not the
first people to make a book club
and i think it's because of two things
one
is that we have a facilitator for each
of our books
and in this case it was me who granted
i'm pretty extroverted and i was totally
fine pinging people on slack and being
like hey
it's thursday night time to meet but you
don't have to be that pushy
rather the point of the facilitator is
that every week there is an agenda
and if no one is able to uh give that
presentation for that week then the onus
is on the presenter to take that upon
themselves or else
the book might kind of like falter to
the white side
the other component is a collaborative
infrastructure
and for our case we use github and
this image as well as the text before
this are linked so feel free to
uh go out to our github but or get up
with three
folders the first is our presentations
so
the actual markdown presentations from
each week
the second folder contains a book down
of
all the questions and answers collated
from the slack channel so that you don't
have to sift through that
and the last folder is a data folder and
in this folder
we kind of uh took that concept of
applications and took a data set and
drilled down into it where each chapter
we applied that to this data set of our
own
now to talk about side dishes so
when we started this book club at the
outset
the goal was essentially learn the
contents of the chapters but we ended up
learning all of these external
uh things as well so i personally
onboarded people
onto how to use github in a
collaborative sense
and collaborate on a single project we
also learned
a lot about our markdown html and css
and lastly and maybe even most
importantly
we were still leveling up on our
presentation skills
in these times where we're all isolated
and alone
so i want to leave you now with a recipe
card
essentially to recreate this recipe that
worked for us
and the recipe here is kind of i broke
it down
into seven steps the first is pick a
book
what book do you want to learn uh the
second is
find an online community to make this as
asynchronous
as possible the third is to blast it on
social media
the fourth is some books are you know
have natural breaks that might not be
the chapters so you might
chop them into segments that are uh
logical breaks and then
you know take a pulse on the group and
on yourself
and see what's working in that precious
hour that you're meeting together and
don't be afraid to switch it up
then lastly i think it was really
awesome and fun that we utilized
applications of the chapter rather than
just keeping it theoretical
and of course in the end have fun so
there's a link to the slack channel here
because i would really like if you are
going to create a book club to
just let us know what works and what
didn't and
thank you so much for listening to this
talk
you